Salut, aujourd'hui dans Libé il y a eu un article
sur les youtubeurs et sur le YouTube game en général
et j'ai été cité à l'intérieur
et en ce moment, tous les youtubeurs, tous les créateurs
parlent du changement d'algorithme
enfin l'algo qui est toujours modifié de toute manière en permanence
des pertes d'abonnés ça aussi je le subis et cetera
mais c'est pas de ça que je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais répondre à une question que j'ai beaucoup reçu
sur facebook et par mail
et sur Instagram aussi
ça a été une petite récurrence de l'année
je l'ai jamais traitée
comme on arrive en fin de l'année, je me dis je vais le faire au moins une fois
voici mes 5 conseils si jamais vous voulez vous lancer sur YouTube
en 2017
Générique ! :)
(musique du générique)
Je sais pas si je suis le meilleur placé pour donner des conseils
en tout cas ce sont les miens et ils me correspondent donc peut-être
vous trouverez des choses inspirantes à l'intérieur
le premier conseil que je pourrais vous donner
c'est de vous donner des objectifs
mais attention, quand on dit "objectifs"
c'est pas un objectif de nombre d'abonnés avant telle date
c'est pas non plus un objectif de vues quotidiennes
pour la simple et bonne raison que ce sont
des objectifs sur lesquels vous pouvez pas influer directement
donnez-vous des objectifs qui vous concernent vous directement
dans l'exemple de ce que j'ai fait cette année
mon objectif était de faire une vidéo par jour
pendant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
peu importe le nombre d'abonnés
peu importe le nombre de vues
qui ont été faites au cours de l'année
je gardais ce défi et je remplissais mon objectif à moi
donc quoi qu'il arrive
je ne peux être que satisfait
lorsque j'ai rempli l'objectif
dans le sens où il ne tient qu'à moi de le faire ou pas
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire
c'est pas vous qui allez décider que les gens vont vous suivre ou pas
c'est pas vous qui allez décider que les gens regardent ou pas
mais vous pouvez avoir des objectifs sur ce que vous vous faites
par exemple la périodicité
par exemple la manière de filmer
par exemple un certains type de contenu
les objectifs c'est toujours stimulant
2eme conseil : trouvez qui vous êtes
au-delà du contenu, de ce que vous allez produire
trouvez qui vous êtes et ce qui vous passionne réellement
j'aurais pu parler par exemple de gaming parce que j'aime bien jouer aux jeux vidéo
mais je m'y connais pas tellement
on ne va pas dire que je suis un passionné des jeux vidéos
ce n'est pas un truc que je suis en permanence
ce n'est pas un truc que je fais en permanence
ça ne m'aurait pas correspondu
vous devez savoir profondément qui vous êtes
comme ça peu importe le contenu que vous produisez
il est sincère
et vous devez faire ou parler de ce que vous aimez faire
ou de ce que vous aimez parler
ça ne veut pas dire de ne pas travailler, faire un texte, une mise en scène, tout ce que vous voulez
mais ça doit partir de vous ça doit vous ressembler
sinon vous allez pas le tenir dans le temps
en 3e conseil, qui serait surement d'ailleurs mon meilleur conseil
allez vous former sur le Creator Academy
dans la Creator Academy sur YouTube vous tapez
YouTube Creator Academy
vous allez trouver ça très facilement
il y a énormément de cours
c'est très bien fait
c'est exactement ce qu'on retrouver dans les YouTube Space
quand on va faire les workshop
c'est hyper précis et c'est assez drôle parce que ça a pas l'air tellement utilisé
moi je me suis formé à fond avec ça et ça répond à toutes les questions
en terme de stratégie, en terme de stratégie de contenu
en terme de production : comment produire,
en terme de réseau
en terme de communication
il y a tout dans la Creator Academy
allez-y, foncez
il y a plein de cours, c'est parfait
4e conseil : pensez à faire des choses viables
la viabilité, c'est-à-dire est-ce que dans le temps c'est viable
je vais prendre un contre-exemple
imaginez que pour vos premières vidéos
vous mobilisiez beaucoup de personnes
vous mettiez peut-être un peu de sous même, sur le tournage
que ce soit quelque chose de très long à faire, très long à produire
lorsque vous allez mettre la vidéo en ligne
si elle a pas beaucoup de vues
vous allez être complètement démotivés
parce que pour faire la prochaine
il faut remettre tout ça en place, c'était compliqué
dans un premier temps, faites un contenu viable c'est-à-dire
pas extrêmement contraignant à produire
vous aurez déjà énormément de contraintes
entre le montage, l'habillage, la mise en ligne
découvrir tout ce qu'il y a à découvrir
répondre aux commentaires si jamais vous êtes quelqu'un de plutôt proche des gens qui vous regardent
je crois vraiment que quand on commence il faut
simplifier la tâche au maximum
moi c'est ce que j'ai fait je filme tout avec la legria, j'ai juste une lumière, je fais mon montage sur FinalCut
pourtant c'est déjà extrêmement long et compliqué
si j'avais eu un setup plus complexe que j'aurais pas eu de vie et cetera j'aurais lâché le défi en cours de route
donc faites des choses viables
euh n'investissez pas plus que vous pouvez investir après dans le long terme
faites des choses que vous pouvez reproduire d'une manière aisée
ça veut pas dire facile, mais ça veut dire vous savez que vous êtes capable de le reproduire régulièrement
sans problème
et enfin, mon dernier conseil
c'est pensez à la "partageabilité" je sais pas si ce mot existe
et à l'actualité
c'est pas quelque chose que je fais beaucoup moi
pour le coup, mais
ça marche plutôt bien
en terme de... des vidéos qui marchent
de se fier à l'actualité, de faire en fonction des tendances
un film qui sort, une actualité récente
d'être dans l'ère du temps, là c'est Noël en ce moment
il y a pas mal de youtubeurs qui font des calendriers de l'Avent
que c'est en rapport direct avec Noël
essayez d'être dans l'ère du temps
et ce qu'on entend derrière la "partageabilité" ça veut dire que
est-ce que si quelqu'un regarde la vidéo, est-ce qu'il a envie de la partager
en général on partage les vidéos où on apprend quelque chose
où on a vu quelque chose d'un peu WTF (What The F*ck)
vous pouvez prendre ces deux contraintes en tête
je vous le dit c'est pas quelque chose moi que j'ai fait, mais
euh, force est de constater que ça fonctionne très très bien
il y a même des personnes qui tiennent des calendriers dans des fichiers
où ils ont marqué la sortie de tous les blockbusters de l'année
les évènements qu'il y aura de marquant dans l'année
certains évènements sportifs de l'année
comme ça ils savent, quand ils écrivent
que telle vidéo du mois de juin va plus parler de ci, celle du mois de juillet de cela,  et cetera
c'est plutôt intéressant
voilà pour les 5 conseils si vous voulez vous lancer sur YouTube en 2017
ben faites le en fait, faites les vidéos que vous avez envie de faire
peut-être vous en ferez 1, peut-être vous en ferez 100
peut-être vous n'arrêterez jamais, peut-être vous arrêterez très vite
mais ne vous privez pas de l'envie de le faire
juste, ne focalisez pas sur les vues et sur les abonnés
ça paraît facile à dire comme ça, mais tout ceux qui ont fait des vidéos sont passés par peu de vues et peu d'abonnés donc
ça empêche pas d'avoir envie de faire les vidéos
faites-les d'abord pour vous avec vos propres objectifs
mais n'hésitez pas à le faire, vous avez pas grand chose à perdre en fait
si une vidéo ne vous plait plus, que vous l'assumez plus, ben vous l'effacerez c'est pas très grave
et si vous avez déjà une chaine et que vous-même vous avez un conseil
qui vous semblait ultra pertinent à rajouter
n'hésitez pas à le mettre dans les commentaires
ce sera très bien pour les personnes qui veulent en faire
ou celle qui en font déjà, de lire un peu l'expérience des autres
comme moi je vous faisais partager la mienne aujourd'hui
si la vidéo vous a plu, comme tous les jours, vous pouvez la liker ou vous abonner
rendez-vous demain à 17h00, ciao !
(musique de fin)